thank you president mrs von der
layen today is an important day of those
that make history
the future of the union is in our hands and my
political group that has been there since the beginning
and has europeanism in its dna wants to
continue building this europe of ours
we have  a responsibility towards the
citizens who have given us their trust
and that is why we want to act
responsibly we want to be
sure that in the next five years we
lay the foundations for a project and
for a sustainable future for
all Europeans allow me
that one day  as today I remember a great
pro-European who just 40 years ago took
the floor in this parliament they free me
in that plenary session held just after
the first direct elections in 1979 he
made an appeal that is
worth remembering today he lamented
how slowly the
European democracy and why
the suffrage elections had taken too long
and also lamented why  Because the
European institutions still seemed
distant from the citizenry, that is why he
asked MEPs to be able
to get to work beyond
ideological and geographical differences
to solve people's problems
and above all to connect
with young people 40 years after this
speech is today more alive than ever
to us socialists it still seems to us that
European democracy is advancing too
slowly we have put a lot of hope into
the project of the speech en candidat and
we have also fought for the transnational lists
but on this occasion
we have not achieved it however  we do not
give up, European democracy has no
going back,
that is why we welcome your commitment, Mr.
Love of the People, to resume and
perfect the process of the
candidate speech for 2024. We also
want Europe to solve the problems of the
people who are capable of facing the
challenges.  and we have to
know that before giving our support to
to chair the committee we
need whether it will be knowing whether you will be able
to lead the change that the citizens are asking of us
and the transformation that the
young Europeans are asking of us,
you have sent us a letter that points in
the right direction, proposing progress,
but now you have the chance  to
further specify you assume the
objective of combating the
climatic urgency and of translating that ambition into
legislation that law is necessary
as well as setting binding objectives
to meet our commitments to
reduce emissions by 2030 but in
addition to the ecological transformation
for us it is  It is essential that no one
is left behind and that is why we are glad to see
that you accept the fund for a
just transition. It also includes the need
to launch an investment plan
for a sustainable Europe. It is important
that it be clear that an important part
of this effort must be  come from
public investments when we ask to
introduce the objectives of
sustainable development in the European semester
we just want them to be taken into account
as a principle we want measurement
criteria and
indicators to also be introduced we do not
want governments that invest in an
economic transformation that takes care of
the people who  they create new
opportunities and lay the foundations for
a sustainable future that is why we insist
and that is also what you have stated in your letter
regarding flexibility in economic rules
and the incorporation
of unemployment insurance
Europe has to protect the most
vulnerable that is why we will support  always
from our political group the
European social pillar and specifically the
children's guarantee and the youth guarantee sir
address the people we need a
more forceful action against poverty
in general to finance all these
policies each one must do their
part also the big ones
technology corporations you want them to
contribute their  s and with its taxes on
the common effort, but it has thought of a
figure, it
also mentions that the situation must be protected
and the workers of the new
platforms must be improved, and here you will have a
political group that will support a directive in
that sense, I am glad to see that  on
issues of gender equality we are
on the same line because you know that for
my political group it is a clear priority to
adopt a binding equality strategy
and to include gender violence
as one of the crimes
contemplated in the union's treaties
is undoubtedly a  good start you say that you are going
to defend the rule of law and
propose a new mechanism to ensure
its compliance can you explain to us
what that mechanism would consist of I think that
many men and women in this room would be
reassured to verify that
you do indeed intend
to maintain the rule of law  demand that
the current commission has shown and specifically the
commissioner frans timmermans in terms of
l  ulo flow regarding the management of
migration we appreciate your proposal to
act with more solidarity
the member states and to end
the dublin reform we need to talk
about solidarity we need to talk about
humanitarian corridors it is not only
about reinforcing the security of increasing the
troops of  frontex is also about
saving people's lives and for
that we need a rescue system
that does not criminalize ngos and a
system of humanitarian visas only then will
we rise to the occasion
sir address the people we are here to
listen we don't want  an
institutional crisis that further delays the
changes that Europe needs but we
need guarantees that in the
coming years
Europe will be able to face the
necessary measures my political group
will make a decision this afternoon have no
doubt that it will do so thinking of what is best
for Europe in men  and women who
want to regain confidence and
hope in the project  or European and on
that path we will find ourselves in the
exciting task of building more and better
Europe, thank you very much
[Applause]